all right shall i
share my screen yes please let's make
sure that
you can see this okay so our last
thought for the morning session is
william krishner
krishner hopefully um yes talk about
quantum studio
missing classical complexity please all
right thank you for the introduction
um so i guess to
well i'm going to start by sort of
summarizing this work and explaining the
relevant background
and to summarize this work in one slide
um
the main objects i'm going to be talking
about are something called pseudo-random
quantum states which will
i'll usually abbreviate as prs's um
and intuitively what these are are i
guess computational approximations to
the heart measure
and what that means is that these are
states that look
like her random states to any
computationally bounded adversary
um i'll give you a more formal
definition later in the talk but
um this is mostly what the talk is going
to be about
and i guess the question that i try to
answer in this work and in this talk is
this
very kind of deliberately broad question
which is where do pseudorandom states
uh fit into the complexity theoretic
landscape so
how do they relate to complexity classes
and other
cryptographic primitives
and i guess what i'm going to try to do
for the rest of this introduction
is first tell you why you should care
about pseudo-random states
i'm going to tell you a little bit about
what we know uh in regards to this
question and then i'm
finally going to try to explain why uh
the answers we have to this question are
kind of unsatisfactory
perhaps even raise more questions than
the answer and so
um that's what i'm going to do in the
introduction that'll bring me right into
the results
and i think with that i'm going to get
started although maybe before i proceed
one thing i will mention is that for
this talk i'm just going to be talking
about pseudorandom states but actually
for this work um almost everything that
i prove in this work also applies to a
stronger object called pseudorandom
unitaries
so i figured i would just mention that
but otherwise i'm not going to mention
pseudo and unitarians again in this talk
uh okay so first off so why should you
care about pseudorandom states well
i'd say there's probably three main
obvious applications of pseudorandom
states and perhaps the most
obvious one is cryptography so
to do random states these are a
cryptographic primitive hence we expect
that you can use them for cryptographic
protocols
and indeed i think well there's one
example we know which is that you
can use pseudo-random states to
construct quantum money schemes
but there's you know very likely other
applications that we just don't know
about
a second natural application of
pseudo-random states is in
physical simulation or physical
computation say you're taking some
average
over par random states or generic
looking states
maybe you're doing some computation
involving thermalization
uh and there um
well you could use information theoretic
approximations to our random states but
these can potentially be
uh computationally expensive to prepare
and in that case
pseudo-random states can in some cases
potentially be
cheaper i guess for some of these
applications
uh and finally there's what i think is
maybe the most exciting
application of pseudorandom states this
is a connection to
black hole physics that was recently
established by golan fefferman and
vaserani and they showed that
essentially any possible resolution to
some
very big questions in blackboard physics
have to be answered using some language
involving
uh complexity theoretic pseudorandomness
and in particular something in the ads
cft correspondence
so i think no matter which way you look
at it whether you're a cryptographer a
complexity theorist or a physicist
uh pseudorandom states are something
that we have good
motivations to want to understand
so um with that i'm going to finally
give you the
the formal definition of pseudo-random
states and this is it's here so
um an ensemble of states which is keyed
by say
end bit strings is pseudorandom if the
following two properties hold
one it should be possible to efficiently
generate copies of these states given
one of these keys and two there's a sort
of computational
indistinguishability criterion uh which
says that
uh to any polynomial uh to any
polynomial time quantum adversary
the advantage that this adversary has in
distinguishing
uh copies of this pseudo-random state
from copies of a harm random state
is at most negligible in the security
parameter
if you're a cryptographer this
definition should look very familiar
because this is
uh very similar to the definition of
pseudorandom generators
and in fact there's really only two key
differences right one is that instead of
a
being an approximation to the uniform
distribution these are
approximations to horizontal states and
the other
is that we allow the adversary to have
multiple copies so any polynomial number
of copies
of this quantum state and this is
motivated by the no cloning principle
where
having many copies of state is
potentially more useful than just a
single copy
um one thing i should also mention is if
you've heard of t
designs these are not the same as t
designs and there's
two crucial differences uh one is that
um for t designs this t here this this
parameter the number of copies this is
fixed in advance
whereas for pseudorandom states we
require security against
um all polynomially bounded t so you
can't fix this t in advance
but the other key difference is that uh
um t designs are an information
theoretic notion
of approximation to the harm measure so
rather than just considering polynomial
time adverse areas
t designs require security against
essentially any possible adversary or
any quantum measurement basically
okay so this is uh this is what
pseudoendostates are
so uh with that so what do we know about
pseudo-random states
well uh in the same paper in which the
uh pseudonymous states were defined in
2018 it was shown
that if quantum secure one-way functions
exist
then pseudo-ending states also exist uh
and i think for for many people this is
fairly convincing evidence that
pseudo-random states exist
uh one-way functions we usually think of
these as a you know mini-crypt primitive
uh these are in line with um
pseudo-random functions pseudo-random
generators and the assumptions we need
to construct one-way functions are
generally much weaker than the
assumptions we need to construct
say public peak photography or
indistinguishability obfuscation
so uh i think for for most people this
is you know sufficient evidence to be
convinced that pseudonym states it says
um so this is this is something we know
but
what's sort of more poorly understood is
uh in some sense the other direction so
assuming pseudo-random states exist then
what else must be true
um are there other cryptographic
primitives or complexity theoretical
implications
of the existence of pseudorandom states
and in fact this was even raised as a
an explicit open problem in this paper
uh 2018 they asked
is there a congress to this theorem so
uh assuming pseudorandom states exist
does this imply that one-way functions
must exist
um so what i'm going to do next is sort
of show you
an example of a problem
where we can sort of show that assuming
pseudo-random states exist
this problem must be hard but at the
same time we sort of
can't really show this and i'm going to
explain what i mean
and what i'm going to do is i'm going to
show
that in some sense a qma protocol so a
quantum merlin arthur protocol can break
pseudo-random states so qma as we know
this is the class of problems that are
decided by
um well as i said a qma protocol this is
sometimes described as being like the
quantum analog of np and what this means
is that
uh these are things that can be decided
by
um so well this is two players there's
arthur who is this
computationally bounded and skeptical
verifier
and merlin who is this all-powerful uh
magical wizard who's potentially
untrustworthy and
merlin's goal is to basically convince
arthur by sending him
some quantum state let's say
that the input satisfies some property
and so what i'm going to show is that a
a qma protocol can make prss and hence
in some sense if pseudorandom states
exist then
it must be hard for polynomial time
quantum algorithms to decide
this kind of qma problem and the input
uh that the problem just goes like this
so
uh suppose arthur has copies of this
state psi which is either
pseudorandom or is har random so here's
what merlin can do merlin can
send arthur uh a description of some
quantum circuit c
and merlin basically claims that if you
apply this circuit c to the all zero
state
you will get back a state that is close
to psi
and this is something that arthur can
verify since arthur has many copies of
the state
you can use even just the swap test
let's say to
generate a bunch of copies and see if
they match up
um and so why does this work well
uh if psy is drawn from the
pseudo-random ensemble
then we know by nature of the efficient
generating algorithm of the pseudo-end
of ensemble
that there must exist a short quantum
circuit that produces that state
so in that case merlin can always pass
this test
on the other hand if psi is a heart
random state uh it's not hard to show by
essentially just a counting argument
that actually no
polynomial size quantum circuit can even
approximate
psi uh to reasonable error
and so in that case merlin can basically
pass this test
with essentially negligible probability
so
in that sense like i said we've shown
that there's this qma problem
which uh must be hard if you believe
that secures the random states exists
uh but okay i said there was sort of an
issue with this construction
so what is that um well the problem with
this is that
while this is like a quantum merlin
arthur protocol this is not actually
defining a qma language right so
complexity classes like np qma bqp
these are defined in terms of like i
said languages which are subsets
of n-bit strings so the input we always
think of the input as being some
classical input
but here the input to this problem this
you know copies of psi
is somehow inherently a quantum state
it's not a string
uh and so it's actually not really clear
at all whether
one can reduce breaking pseudorandom
states to an actual qma decision problem
and this was actually my original
motivation for this work was i kind of
realized you know this
something weird is going on here uh it's
not clear if you can
um reduce this problem of breaking
pseudorandom states to any
classical decision problem actually um
and so i was basically wondering
you know is this just um
a conceptual issue is there maybe a more
clever reduction you can construct that
would allow you to break pseudorandom
states
uh if you could decide qma problems uh
so this was sort of my
motivation for the work and is there a
question in the chat
there's a comment that says instead of
using the swap test you could just
say inverse inside because it's from
normal
uh right
well okay yeah i guess you could do that
uh yeah maybe that's even more trivial
i guess you would just have you just
have to repeat it enough times to get
the
your confidence to be sufficiently high
but yeah yeah i guess that should work
um yeah maybe the swap test is overkill
okay so that's essentially um
all the background i want to say this
actually brings me straight into
um the first results of this work
which shows uh that in some sense this
is not just a
conceptual misunderstanding there's
actually something weird going on here
so uh what do i do well i can show that
there exists
an oracle a quantum oracle such that the
following two properties hold
one bqp equals qma relative to this
oracle o
and two pseudorandom states exist
relative to this oracle o
so uh this immediately implies that
uh well okay you know polynomial time
quantum
algorithms can decide qma problems and
so somehow we know that this must be
useless for
for breaking pseudo-random states
because pseudonyms secure pseudo-random
states exist
relative which is oracle but in some
sense this is saying something
even stronger which is uh in my view
rather surprising
because what this is basically showing
is a black box separation
between pseudo-random states and
essentially
all other interesting cryptographic
primitives
um so why is this well in general um
essentially all interesting classical
cryptography
can be broken if p equals np right and
okay b
f equals q a is almost like p equals np
right np is contained in qma
so this basically implies that relative
to this oracle we can decide np problems
in polynomial time on a quantum device
uh and hence there can't be
any secure cryptography or at least
any um any classical photography that is
secure against quantum devices
and yet there can also there can never
less be these pseudo-random states which
are secure
against quantum devices so this was um
yeah this i found this to be very
surprising um
but i guess that's that's what we can
show and
but okay so this also sort of raises
this natural question of well
if uh if qma is not enough power to
break pseudorandom states
then uh what is enough power like what
what suffices can we place any upper
bound on how much power you need to
break uh superman
states um and that brings me to the
second result where we can show that
um if you can solve sharp p complete
problems so if if pqp equals pp
then pseudorandom states do not exist uh
and moreover this even holds relative to
all oracles
so this gives sort of a a nice upper
bound on how much power you need to take
pseudo and upstates
um so these are sort of the two
main results of this work with that in
hand i'm going to
now discuss a few interesting
applications of these results
uh and the first thing i'm going to talk
about is an application
relating to a task called shadow
tomography so this was defined by scott
aronson in 2018 uh so
imagine you're given a list of binary
observables let's say o1 up to om
and you're also given a bunch of copies
of some n qubit state rho
and your goal is given these copies uh
to estimate each of these observables
the expectation of each of the circles
on the state row
up to additive error epsilon um
simultaneously for each of these
now what's interesting about shadow
tomography is that erinson showed
that you can actually use this using
surprisingly few
uh copies of this quantum state so the
number of copies you need is just
polynomial and the number of qubits
uh logarithmic and the number of
observables and
okay also polynomial in this error
parameter epsilon
uh and so in some sense this says that
with a polynomial number of samples you
can actually
simultaneously estimate an exponential
number of different observables
so this is this is quite powerful uh one
thing that was
sort of left open though is are there
any interesting cases in which
this shadow tomography procedure can be
made time efficient
meaning let's say with uh time scaling
that's like comparable to the sample
complexity
well unfortunately there's sort of a
trivial no answer to this
uh and this is just because the inputs
and outputs to this problem are way too
big
right if you're given a list of m
different observables okay that's
already m inputs
you can't hope to get logarithmic
scaling um
those observables if they're given to
you explicitly they're also
way too big in terms of n because these
would be like 2 to the n by 2 to the n
size density matrices so
well of course also there's you know m
possible outputs that you have to list
because you have to list all of these
estimates simultaneously
so as defined you can't hope to make
this
computationally efficient but you can
define well you can change the problem
slightly to make it so it's at least
possible for this to be computationally
efficient so this was something that
aaronson also defined which is
a hyper-efficient shadow topography and
in this
slight variation of the problem it's
essentially the same task
but now the algorithm is allowed to
operate implicitly on both the inputs
and the outputs
rather than explicitly so now instead of
being given this
observable as like an explicit density
matrix the algorithm just gets oracle
access
so we have some oracle that takes an
index and performs the
observable you're still given copies of
the state
but now the the output also gets to be
uh sort of implicit so
rather than listing all of the outputs
explicitly
the algorithm is allowed to basically
return a succinct description
of uh the list of outputs in the form of
some quantum circuit
c so it outputs the description of the
quantum circuit such that
uh when you apply c to i you get back
the
i observable the estimate of this
observable on this stage
so uh this is at least now is at least
conceivably possible that
uh in some interesting cases one could
have an algorithm here that scales
polynomially in n
and also in the logarithm of the number
of measurements
unfortunately though um aronson also
showed that it's actually
impossible to do this efficiently uh if
you're only given
oracle access to these observables so if
you only get black box access then you
cannot hope to do this efficiently
meaning in time like i said polynomial n
log n and epsilon
so uh we could hope to i guess relax
this model even further
uh and that's uh what i'm going to
consider next
so now let's consider a special case of
this where
rather than being given general
observables now all of the observables
are just going to estimate
um fidelities with some pure state side
uh and now rather than uh just being
able to measure this observable you're
gonna get even stronger access you
actually get the ability to produce
copies of psi
um this you can show this also lets you
measure psi of course
so this is sort of strictly more
powerful and there are even i believe
some uh examples of query complexity
separations where the ability to produce
a state can be
potentially exponentially more powerful
than the ability to measure
in a basis containing that state so
this should be strictly easier than
what's on the previous slide
uh and i guess the question here is is
this possible
well what i can show is that actually
even this task
means impossible to do efficiently once
again assuming you just have black box
access
to copies of these states uh and there's
sort of an acute one-line proof of this
uh this is just actually a simple
corollary of our first result
which is that well suppose otherwise
that we did have
an efficient algorithm for this
hyper-efficient shadow tomography with
state preparation
then there would actually be a black box
qma reduction to break through to random
states
but of course this is what our first
year rules out
um and what's what's sort of the proof
of this well
here uh these psi eyes you should think
of these as being like the
the different states in the
pseudo-random ensemble
the state rho is the state which is
either some
copies of a pseudo-random state or
copies of our random state
and here this this output circuit
this is basically what you would feed
into a qma algorithm because you'd be
basically be asking uh is there some i
such that c of i
reports something close to one because
in that case then you've identified
that uh one of these states psi i is
close to
um so that's that's the proof so we can
show that uh even this
the stronger form of um oreos weaker
depending on how you look at it
form of shattered tomography remains
impossible
um okay finally i have just one more
application of our results and this is
something involving
her random oracles so here well
uh sometimes something that we often do
in
class complex state theory is considered
complexity classes
um with a classical band of oracle but
you can also consider
sort of a quantum random oracle so what
this means is that say for
each n-bit string x we choose some
unitary transformation u sub x
uh over n qubits so this is
in dimension two to the power of n
uh and an algorithm basically gets to
query use of x give uh so you see v and
x and it
performs this operation u sub x uh you
can consider complexity classes that
have the ability to query this oracle
uh what we can show is the the following
so
if you can separate dqp from qma
relative to this
uh heart random oracle then you can
actually separate dqp from qma
in the unvalidated world uh so in some
sense what this is saying
is that this smart random oracle is sort
of um
i guess in some sense useless for uh
proving oracle separations
uh because if you could prove like a
query complexity separation between bqpp
and qma
then you would actually separate them in
the unrelativized world
uh and this is in like stark contrast to
um
a classical random work where we can
actually prove unconditionally
that uh bqp is not equal to qma relative
to classical vandomark
so in some sense what this is saying is
that uh classical and quantum random
oracles behave very differently
um i think i should also mention that
depending on how you define
query access i think you can even make
this actually if and only if
um but i think for the purposes of this
work though this is just the
sort of the interesting direction of the
implication
um okay so with that are there any
questions because
otherwise i'm basically just going to
jump into talking
a little bit about some of the proof
techniques in this work
with that last result can you replace
bqp
with qcma or
oh um
how general is this it definitely
generalizes
um i you might be able to replace
with qcma i'm not certain um
yeah that's a good question um but but
yeah i mean i know you can
you can definitely say the same thing
about uh
whatever if you replace this qma with
like
whatever quantum statistical zero
knowledge or like
um some of these other interactive
complexity classes i think the same
thing holds um
how you prove this or um
well okay yeah i'll actually explain a
little bit on the
on this next slide um but well
yeah we'll see so uh so actually so as i
mentioned so this this first result that
we proved
it's this oracle o relative to which uh
one pseudo-random states exist
but two bqp equals qma relative to this
oracle
uh and this oracle o is actually
extremely simple to describe uh consists
of two parts
one is this uh random unitary variable
that i described on the previous slide
and two is basically any p space
complete language
um okay so why does this work well
in some sense uh what we could show is
that
a q a algorithm cannot learn any
non-trivial property of this
random oracle o uh and this turns out to
follow from the
extremely strong concentration of
measuring properties that are exhibited
by
our random unitary transformations
and hence when you're considering you
know qma relative to this oracle
we might as well basically just cross
out this uh this unitary part
this u and we're basically just left
with q a to the p
so q h is p space uh which by standard
complexity theory
is just equal to p space uh and so this
is how you show that bqb equals qma
relative to this oracle because
basically all these
all you can decide is just piece-based
complete languages
um okay so uh what's even simpler i
guess
is showing that pseudo-random states
exist relative to this oracle
uh this turns out to just be a simple
application of the bbb theorem so the
the lower bound
quantum lower bound for unstructured
search uh and this
works just because well um query
complexity doesn't compare
doesn't care about computational
efficiency so
giving this p space oracle does not help
you at all to
break the search problem corresponding
to deciding whether a state is hard
random or pseudo-random
so this is essentially all that goes
into the the first main result
for our second result showing that
pseudo-random states do not exist
if uh bqp can decide sharply complete
problems
uh is sort of two main ingredients that
go into this
one is a classical shadows protocol so
this is actually a form of shadow
tomography
this was introduced by these authors in
2020
uh and the other is the famous
post-selection theorem so showing that
uh post bqp equals uh equals pp which
was proved in 2005.
and so how do we use how do we use these
together well
what this classical shadows protocol
does uh it essentially shows
that in some sense um pseudorandom
states can be
information theoretically broken by an
efficient protocol
there's just some efficient measurements
you could perform such that once you've
taken these measurements of the state
there's just some classical purely
classical post-processing you have to do
to determine whether that state is
pseudo-random or r-random
uh and indeed the measurements are
really simple they're just like
you take random clifford measurements
basically
but this classical prose processing
is potentially hard what we show is that
uh nevertheless using some clever tricks
involving post selection
uh at least for the special case of
distinguishing pseudo-random states from
heart random states
you can do this classical processing
efficiently
um if you can solve uh
problems in post pqp
um so that's essentially everything i
wanted to say about the results
um i think with that
i'm just going to leave you with a few
other problems and then i'll take
questions at the end so
kind of the first and most obvious open
problem i think is
can you prove something like this
instead of with a quantum oracle with a
classical oracle
um i think this is just a nice question
uh we have you know similar questions
where
say we have an oracle separation between
qcma and qma this was proved by erinson
at cooperberg in
2007 i think and it also remains open
whether you can prove that oral
separation with a classical oracle
uh and somehow it seems that like very
similar issues seem to come up here um
in the same sorts of constructions so
i'd be very interested to know if you
can do this with classical oracle
um i think another interesting question
is whether you can give
other evidence for the existence of
pseudorandom states
so you know another way of looking at
what this work does is showing that
uh perhaps it might be possible to base
the existence of pseudo-random states
on weaker assumptions than we usually
think of as being assumptions for
cryptography
right i'm basically wondering can you
instantiate this
some you know interesting and
non-trivial assumption that's like also
possible
um and then finally i think um another
direction that would be interesting to
look at
is what's called quantum meta complexity
so
this means that what is the complexity
of problems that
themselves encode complexity so to give
you an example
uh what if i ask you know how hard is
the following problem
i give you copies of a quantum state and
then i ask you
given those copies to determine the size
of the smallest
quantum circuit that approximately
produces that state
uh how hard is this task well if if
pseudorandom states exist
then this should be hard because it
should not be possible to distinguish
low complexity states from our random
states
but that's basically all we know about
this problem and i'd be
interested to know what else we can say
about this problem especially because
lately a lot of the really interesting
breakthroughs in classical complexity
theory
have involved looking at a problem
through a sort of meta-complexity lens
and i'd be very interested to know which
of these techniques can be ported to
a quantum setting involving quantum
states
um so with that that's about um
everything i had to say so i'd be happy
to take questions
there's even a i guess i have a bonus
slide if
if no one has any questions but
otherwise
i'm happy to hear what you have to say
[Applause]
thank you very much for the uh wonderful
talk let's get to any questions
all right we got one yeah um so for the
impossibility results or the
hyper efficient uh shadow tomography so
these are oracle impossibility results
um is there
a reason like would it be plausible to
try to prove a non-oracle
like a possibility result from a
non-oracle version of it
or is that run into like circuit lower
balancers
oh um
interesting um
i'm not sure i i'm
yeah at first i was just gonna say yeah
maybe like okay
assuming well okay you would certainly
probably need some
computational assumption but you know
whether you can prove something that
using
an assumption okay maybe just like
assuming pseudo-random states exist for
instance
uh i'm not sure
it's a good question
um yeah so earlier you know there was
also this question about how do we
you know prove this results using uh par
random oracles and so that's what i
saved for i guess the last slide uh
so um this is kind of technical which is
why i saved it for the end because i
don't know if i'll be able to explain it
well but
uh basically the the key lemma we use is
this uh
concentration of measure property for
the heart measure so
um if you have some function that is uh
lipschitz continuous and it's defined on
copies of both harmonic mutatories um
then what this shows is that the
probability that this
function deviates substantially from its
average by
more than x let's say uh
it's actually exponentially small um in
the dimension
of the the horizontal state or like it's
the horizontal unitary transformation
so um to give you some idea of what
these parameters are
well so n here this is like you know 2
to the power of little n where n is the
number of qubits
this f of u this is basically the um
acceptance probability of some qma
algorithm so so what does this mean so
here arthur
this is some quantum algorithm a
and here merlin feeds arthur some
witness state psy and merlin is
basically taking a maximum overall
possible witness state psi over the
probability that earth accepts
and finally t is basically the number of
queries that arthur makes to this
unitary transformation
so if we think of t as being like
polynomial and little n
uh let's say x is like constant like one
third
and uh this big n is two to little n
then this is basically saying that the
probability if you choose a a random
matrix that this deviates substantially
from the average is
is not just exponentially small and
little n it's actually
like doubly exponentially small in
little n
um and this is sort of the the key
property of the heart measure that we're
using
to prove these uh oracle separations and
to prove
that uh basically a hog of oracle is
useless to a qma algorithm just because
well like i said the probability that
steviates is like doubly exponentially
small
but there's only like singly
exponentially many different
qma algorithms essentially
so are there any other questions
oh uh anurag asks is there any uh reason
why there's no dependence on k
actually this is just the interesting
part of this there's no dependence on k
whatsoever
and this is sort of in contrast to
um i guess if these were like a discrete
random variable they would
like have to be some dependence on k uh
the number of copies but yeah there's
actually no dependence on k
just kind of interesting i should
mention i did not prove this level this
is uh
you can find this in like a textbook
about concentration
measure
[Applause]
the uh again session
[Music]
um
thank you